hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the second semi-final match between
magnus claus and enyani ponishi as you
know magnus is in a pretty tough spot he
lost the first match and now he's losing
the second match so now now we are in
game three and magnus needs to win both
game three and game four to even get
back
into the match to try uh to try and
force tie breaks
so without further ado let's check it
out as this is uh this is a crazy game
uh jan with the white pieces opens with
e4
we have c5 by magnus going for the
sicilian defense
uh knight to f3 we have e6 and now d4
ion strikes in the center we have
captures captures and now
queen to b6 already trying to mix it up
uh we have knight to c3 this is the
so-called the cleanest variation
uh we have a6 uh taking away the b5
square from the white knights and
now a3 and here magnus goes back queen
to c7 it's a very very rare line queen
b6 back to c7
only a handful of games in the database
that reach this exact same position and
there is uh only bishop to d3 as a known
move here but here
uh nipple plays g3 and it's already as
of move seven then we have a completely
new game so magnus definitely ready to
fight
and uh well there is nothing left to do
other than that so here uh preparing to
think a little light square bishop also
setting up for bishop to f4 to go after
the queen on c7
uh we have knight to f6 by magnus and
now bishop to g2 we have knight to c6
and the nipple castles with h5 magnus
immediately going for this
flank attack with h5h4 and now knight
captures on c6
b captures and bishop to f4 slowing down
the attack a little bit
magnus advances the pawn with e5 uh this
does take care of this problem but it
weakens the d5 square
when the pawn was on e6 you had some
support for d5 now not so much so
uh you know a double-edged move so here
bishop to g5
and bishop to c5 by magnus so nicely
developing we have queen to f3 by nippon
now
preparing to capture on f6 twice and
magnus just goes d6 uh it's actually a
bit of a trick here because if nepo goes
for it
then magnus has this bishop to g4 uh
chasing the queen and only then
recapturing and
this is now a uh very much playable
position for black
so instead after uh queen to the after
this d6 move we have
h3 in expectance of black of course
pushing uh
the h pawn at some point and now knight
to d7
all right so getting the the knight out
of harm's way and now you will be able
to
uh advance your uh f pawn as well uh and
here we have
rook eight to d1 by yan uh we have
knights to f8 the knight is now coming
to e6 we have knight the a4
uh putting pressure on the bishop here
and knight to e6 now
going after the bishop on g5 bishop back
to e3
and here magnus trade we have captures
captures with the queen
and now finally h4 trying to bust open
neapo's king's side
uh and uh jan just goes knight to b6
it's not going after any pieces he just
wants to get the knight to c4 and then
go after the backwards d6 spawn as we
said it became weak as soon as e5 was
played
so rook to b8 and now knight to c4
very nicely done uh you cannot play d5
it's defended three times by the pawn
bishop and rook so there's no that
so magnus just decides to sacrifice upon
and he
this uh he castles king's side he needs
to win this and he must play anything to
win
uh and here uh nipple just goes um
knight captures on d6 it's a free pawn
so why not
we have h captures on g3 f captures on
g3 and now
rook captures on b2 so grabbing that
pawn
uh we have queen to c3 attacking the
rook and now queen to b8 magnus defends
it with
knight to f5 again nipple with his
knight close to
the uh carlsen's king but now rook to b5
getting the rook out of harm's way
so now the queen can move and the rook
will not be under attack uh
knight the e7 check we have king to h7
and here you you might be noticing that
the
uh g8 and g6 squares are covered and if
you
play something like queen f3 queen h5
this will be checkmate the problem here
you do
you can't go for it right away because
magnus has this very tricky queen a7
check
and that picks up the knight on e7 so
nipple needs to waste the move here
before playing that
so king the h2 now this will very much
be an idea but now
queen to c7 attacking the knight here so
nepal must bring it back we have knights
to f5
and now rook to c5 putting pressure on
the queen and also on the c2 pawn behind
the queen so queen d2
defending both of them uh and now comes
rook to d8
forcing the queen to move with queen
back to f2 and now
rook to c3 so what do you play here as
the a3 pawn is under attack nipple
pushes it we have a4
and now knight to d4 a very nice outpost
for carlson's knight
uh nipple trades here we have knight
captures rook
captures uh sorry knight captures uh
rook captures uh and now queen to e2
uh so again uh queen is trying to get
the h5 maybe go for that f7 pawn if the
black queen moves at some point
uh so here bishop to e6 adding a
defender to the f7 pawn and then now
just
rook captures on d4 so grabbing that
rook e captures
and the queen the h5 check magnus hides
the king king the g8
and now it's a very very uh difficult
position to play especially with so
little time on the clock
magnus was even down uh below a minute
he had some 30 seconds on the clock
nipple hit some
two and a half minutes but there really
is no good move here the position
is just um well very bad for white it
doesn't seem like it but it is nipple
played the rook to f4 here
and now there is one move that really
tops
all the moves uh so feel free to pause
the video here and win the game for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
uh doing absolutely nothing and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's actually
c5 and c5 it basically does nothing
other than advances this pawn you're
preparing c4 this pawn is coming over
here
at some point you might gain access to
this diagonal but
a point being white does not have a move
because
you you you should not move your main
attackers the rook should remain here
the queen should remain here
and just don't move any of that and
you're gonna be fine because now you
don't have
rook here threatening checkmate because
of queen captures on g3 check
and that's it you're you're losing the
game and not much to be done here king
h1 king if eight white's
attack is over you're just gonna hide
the king here and you're getting crushed
there's nothing for for
white to do here so instead after c5 you
don't really have a good move here
you're going to have to play
any move but there really is no good
move here something like moving the
queen but
then black slowly just improves the
position if you move the queen something
like
queen e5 c for d3 create a pass pawn and
so on
uh there really is no good move here for
white so c5 really really crushing
uh but it's easy to miss with half a
minute on the clock so queen to e7 was
played by magnus
uh but now uh the immediate uh rook to
h4 just
going after that checkmate so f6 uh
defending against that uh
and now comes uh
uh now comes the e5 here if you go queen
to h8 it's really nothing you just hide
the king here and
there really is no good continuation
here you might just repeat like this
so instead after f6 nippo decided to go
e5 he
clears this diagonal for the bishop
which might be useful but it's always
uh difficult to get the bishop into the
game as rook captures and c2 would come
with the czech so it's basically just
trading upon
uh f captures queen captures and now
rook captures on c2 by magnus uh we
rook to e4 now putting pressure on the
bishop here
and here d3 uh magnus says you're
welcome to grab my piece because i have
a beautiful past
deep on so near portraits there really
isn't anything better we have captures
characters and captures and magnus goes
d2 now uh threatening to bring the queen
into the game so nipple must put a rook
behind the pass pawn and now magnus
advances the other pass pawn so c5
we have g4 nepo now needs to bring the
king into the game and the c4 by magnus
we have king to g3 and
now c3 by magnus and here nipple makes a
move that doesn't really do him any
favors
he plays king to h4 which is uh the
wrong way to go with your king you have
to play
uh the with the king closer to
this position but first you have to play
something like bishop b5 check and then
you have to shift the bishop over here
to help out
with the defense of the light squares
once the rook moves and now you start
with king f2 and now the d1 square is
defended twice
and if black prepares this with c2 then
you have to give up
the piece but you're up a piece so it
doesn't matter king e2 and you're
defending the d1 square
so this was the way to defend for jan
but he went king to h4
and now it doesn't work here magnus just
started bringing the king into the game
we have bishop to f3 kind of guarding
the d1 square
yes but uh rook to c1 so
c2 uh there you don't you're not really
defending against c2
so rook to d3 by uh yan and now king
e7 uh we have kink the g5 and the now
comes
rook to f1 and again what do you play
here
if you capture on c3 now then just rook
captures
on f3 eliminating that bishop and after
rook captures you just bring a queen
into the game
and that's it it's a game over so after
this rook to f1 move we have rooked the
e3 with
check came to d6 and now rook to d3 with
check magnus just brings the king even
closer and now there's really not all
that much to do here
uh young grabbed the on c3 and now
everything is clear rook captures and
see three
rook captures and now uh d1 uh queen
and here you really don't have a uh a
chance rook to f5 check was played the
king the e4
ended now a5 so the rook is now guarding
everything you're hoping to create some
sort of a fortress
but the position simply does not allow
it queen to d6 was played king to h4
and now after g6 it was in this position
that yani ponchi resigned to the game
and it took two days and seven games for
magnus to grab
one point from yan so jan was this close
to
already eliminating magnus from the
tournament and getting that uh one spot
into the finals uh but magnus was able
to bounce back and
now uh the score is still in john's
favor but if magnus wins the final game
then magnus will
uh force tie breaks and then uh then
anything can happen so we'll see what
happens in game four
and willian be able to at least hold on
to a draw or will magnus take the win
uh we'll see so here you resign because
uh you have to move the rook and you
can't keep an eye on everything if you
go rook to f7 then just queen to d8 with
check king g3 you're gonna capture on a5
you've eliminated this pawn now you're
gonna start pushing this pawn to victory
and
the rook is unable to help out at all so
g6 uh nipple resigns and magnus grabs
his first win against nepo
so that's it hope you guys enjoyed it
congratulations to everyone who founded
that to do absolutely nothing movie
wasn't an easy one to find
i would like to thank mr hoody guy
connor watts david kimura nicolas virkos
and peter smith for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the magnus crossing
invitational checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day